now let's go to the runway for the
supermodel Fashion Show staged by
photographer Matthew Rolston
presenting the costumes from Sense and
Sensibility Tyra Banks
Arina pantalla bar
Patricia Velasquez Brandi
daniela von Groff's Veronica Webb
presenting the costumes from Braveheart
Michael Bergen Joel West Matt King
John Francis
for setting the costumes from Richard
the third
frederique Marcus shaken bird
presenting the costumes from 12 monkeys
- Beckford
presenting the costumes from restoration
Cameron David bowl rigid Hall
okay how about our supermodels in those
fabulous costumes ladies and gentlemen
first one of the night and the Oscar
goes to James agents in for restoration
you
I want to thank the Academy and Miramax
and particularly I want to thank the
wonderful team of people that cut and
sew and print and dye the costumes that
you see tonight they're the real heroes
of this I want to really dedicate this
to my wife my beloved wife and my
darling daughter Grace many thanks